I did not think Gwyneth could get any
more dangerous to the public but then
she posted this he eats something about
12. have coffee have bone broth for
lunch I'll do Pilates and thread sauna
for 30 minutes dinner I try to eat
according to paleo really important for
me to support my detox what I'm hearing
is that she eats nothing for breakfast
just black coffee until noon then has
bone broth for lunch which clocks in at
a measly 40 calories per cup then does a
whole hour of exercise 30 minutes of
sweating in a sauna and then has some
vegetables for dinner to support her
detox so many red flags in such a short
30 second interview for the Love of All
That is Holy you do not need to detox
your body does this naturally every fun
day just by peeing pooping breathing and
sweating this woman is going to die on
the detox Hill because she basically
created this hysteria and is profiting
off it every [__] day I will die on
my own Hill trying to prove her wrong